talk about value added to society what
makes Society run okay no no no wait
wait wait wait wait wait let me let me
let me let me uh
this is your final warning one more time
you're gonna go okay so I don't know I'm
sorry okay I think it's very important
all right thank you thank you all right
all right what did you say respect your
guest okay actually you can go now thank
you goodbye yeah goodbye um Security
will escort you out
wow
wow yeah that's pretty yeah I I've
warned you like three times
to stop over talking me we read you the
rules at the beginning of the show it's
all right go ahead everyone talking no
all right and now you're gonna keep
talking about goodbye
exclude my conversation and everything
from this video no it's live so I'll see
ya
I love you